[Music]
in stop swallowing things news no one's
ever said that to me
submitted by oatmeal crackers mmm
a man died after allegedly swallowing a
gecko as a party dare I heard about this
alive what did the gecko do yeah that's
[ __ ] up cuz the diner talk was it in
Hawaii no this was in Australia maybe he
died because the gecko clawed its way
out and there's no and he couldn't say
15% on his car shine I heard that that's
bad cuz hey what did the gecko do right
and feed now this guy's dead who wins
no one geckos are pretty cute though
hell yeah they're cute and also like
what a horrible way to go
poisonous man meat it could probably got
lodged in his throat it was I think it
oh yeah yes I know I actually know this
one oh you do cuz I did my homework on
before taking this I didn't get any
homework oh I see
all right so this guy his name was David
thirty-four years old
well he should have known better he shot
there are three oh he took it there with
the help he's too old for this [ __ ]
his son dared him okay if the gecko was
cooked that's fine that is but I don't
know if that's much of a dare at this
point no that's not a good as humans do
we eat what did I do
well they're alive octopus octopus squid
in Korea it's pretty sad yeah boy stirs
but raw they're smart clams we don't
really they bring them out like a whole
one IVs LiveOps lobster life we talk
about live lobster cow yeah in Cape Town
you bit into it when it wasn't know so
they like crack it open well then it's
dead once it crack it's spa yeah yeah so
that's I like they call it live because
it's still like moving and [ __ ] just
like with this the octopus like we've
had that in the same meal actually it
was but the thing is but then in Korea
they give you the whole one to know
anymore it's illegal
oh really what's illegal they give you
the whole baby octopus and then I mean
there's there's videos of them the way
that they eat is they eat it with the
head first and then the tentacles are
like sticking on there
anyway so this guy here he was at some
party and they dared him to eat a small
gecko and so some people are saying that
they did see him eating other people at
the party said I never saw him eat it so
we don't know what room were they
standing and this is easily fixable yes
what ended up there was the atrium
obviously what ended up killing him was
that he was infected with salmonella oh
he died three days later
gecko got that there that's pretty
common in lizards and [ __ ] yeah yeah
reptiles yeah I'd say after you handle
like any turtle or reptile or amphibian
yeah that's why yeah I had no you don't
want to be playing with no frogs and
then like I don't know my [ __ ] typing
on your tongue honey oh my god when I
was a kid I would let the live and hang
off my tongue doesn't boiling the lizard
kill the Salmonella like is it one of
those things cuz you know like you
talking a lot about cooking liver no
recipe okay he's like if you covered in
barbecue sauce is probably good because
people eat red your sliders they eat
Turtles
yeah I think it's like chicken just
Salmonella and chicken but if you fully
cook it then it kills the Salmonella so
they're saying here that yes it he got
salmonella infection and that his
symptoms were horrifying you do tell
what salmonella do to you he was
throwing up green bile him urine had
turned black Oh
his stomach was so bloated that he looks
six months pregnant
and there was also fluid leaking from
his stomach and his lung from his
stomach what part of his stomach was
rotting from the inside he was in so
much pain so much pain that the doctors
had to put him into an induced coma so
he Oh
and so during surgery is when he passes
so he waited too long to go to the
hospital maybe like maybe we don't feel
symptoms oh my cousin once ate a
McDonald's sandwich I have been sitting
in the Sun for a whole day and she got
salmonella poisoning and it was like
almost like after she ate it was like
that she got ii had to go to hospital
how does that happen why would she do
have mayonnaise on it and she didn't
think about it she was like a kid
all right she's like I thought
McDonald's is invincible how does that
happen no right you can leave the
McDonald's sandwich out and like it
won't even have mold on it after a years
I'm sure we did a video I saw that [ __ ]
the meaning is pretty weak agreed you
fool who pressured you my name is David
and I'll take a dare yeah but you know
what you show anybody a good picture
like that we're gonna feel bad room
let's see what should he have been like
like this yeah you've been like the
[ __ ] cat goes sure no party that's
like a wedding photo gopher they added
oh god I just feel bad for his kids he
got three kids that was the last meal
he's ever had mmm well he did mom three
days later isn't he yeah I'm sure we
have the hospital jello it's not things
last man that's wise me oh yeah nothing
real that killed them ah it's okay three
kids because of a [ __ ] party trip
yeah any people gonna ask how did your
dad die he swallowed a get go I was just
named it's poison yeah oh you know what
my bad
so it was a three day thing was that
that's when he started showing symptoms
but he didn't die until two weeks later
clogged oh sorry
death dude they're doing in college
that's like a fraternity in induction
thing if they're making them swallow
live goldfish Oh remember jackass did
that [ __ ] whereas TiVo would do it then
you throw it back up and would still be
alive yeah but now they're doing it I'm
seeing in colleges where they make them
swallow a goldfish and that's it are you
looking at colleges don't worry okay
I'm not even gonna ask why because I
used to be that age and now I understand
nevermind what are you waiting that he's
just saying he was a dumb fat age did
sound like Asian baby didn't make sense
I'm like oh maybe men age yeah college
kid but this guy was 31 34 and I did
some student you at 34 hey we still do
stupid [ __ ] out on JV party okay
doesn't that guy look like he's got the
goofy face like he's the clown of the
group like he's
Wow dude there's a soccer trophy out
there I nobody should ever get some day
of that you stick up your ass
no so I was actually at I was in
Portland and I was there to meet like
Cristiano Ronaldo or some [ __ ] like that
oh yes and we were doing like a YouTube
video and then we got me and my friend
we were alone with the very prestigious
trophy the soccer trophy very well known
target Rafi and we're not soccer fans
when I'm big soccer guys and so so we so
we we tea-bagged it Oh which trophy is
this pretty big deal trophy yeah stupid
[ __ ] right stupid [ __ ] wait really like
what do you think that like your skin's
gonna like yeah you're so [ __ ] stupid
it was just about Fanning it was about
doing the exact yeah right it's that
[ __ ] it's a jackass thing were you like
so you were that guy that dipped his
nuts in the [ __ ] salsa thing that's
painful that's too far - I put my balls
on a cold trophy it was funny and you
troubled like how many people can say
that they've done that see that's what
it was about if it was the Stanley Cup
they have a guy that actually travels
with the cup that's his full-time job
and that's why he's been to like Mount
Everest he's been to on planes because
people if you win the any to the hockey
championship every player gets 24 hours
with the trophy you can do whatever you
want some of us feel a little like
Disney most people drink out of it and
like he follows that we follow this the
training cup every year like just get
one and they shine it up why I don't
know why they let us alone with the
trophy wife who's letting teen boys
alone with the World Cup it wasn't a
teenager put I was in my 20s well you
remember that feeling and that that
feeling of winning that's right but you
can't lose your life to that so that's
not it's to me no it's just that kind of
stupid what are you talking about stupid
mentality I don't know if he thought
that I snorted
you know those Pixy sticks I don't even
know why I was like you're gonna do it
burn [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] burned it burns
just putting in your mouth and I'm like
[ __ ] yup I'm gonna do it like chalk here
pressure do you think that was peer
pressure he was just like a woman I just
wanted to be cool he's just easy to be
like this is all thought a Christmas
party by the way it was that there was
what if he just eats crazy [ __ ] every
year but this time you know bit back
yeah he's like Crocodile Hunter like you
know he just does edgy [ __ ] you know
he's until the all the way to the edge
dude oh god is that his wife oh stop
looking sorry yeah you have this green
on yeah a privacy screen here oh that's
his wife its partner the mother of his
three daughters the police reaction it's
maybe the Me's reaction to anything I've
ever heard
that was incredible she is uh she's
widowed you're like now I get why you
eat the gecko no maybe it was his mother
because she looked like maybe she could
also be the mother better burned even
better burn thank you
she's whittled you're a load on that one
even I can't back you up there and I'm
pretty [ __ ] up I get it because it
looks really yummy she looks older so
you know I thought it was the mother I
look forward to your apology video would
be really nice well they weren't married
Oh Robert Bresson he took a Cutlass he
doesn't get married so but that was them
that was the mother though yeah the mom
that doesn't make me think thank God I'm
like damn that sucks now she ate she's a
widow with three kids I only like to
talk [ __ ] about criminals by the way and
people who deserve it that's right I'm
not like Telstra knowledge about good
people
oh [ __ ] you've reminded everyone why no
told him to go right let's make her the
bad guy that could be yes alright you
know what you better hope to sorry good
she's the one that was like do it dude
you're a punk you're a [ __ ] she's like
no like that look that guy who committed
suicide because the girl is like get
back in the car you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
kill yourself yeah
yeah yeah I'm I couldn't I can picture a
guy going oh yeah you put a hat on her
like she has a hat a forehead I can see
that because as a guy you want to be
right so [ __ ] bad
you're like you kill yourself and then
you're like my win or like the Gecko
thing she's like I bet you [ __ ] won't
think it's like watch I will and then
laughing now now she's the one raising
the cool when people tell you don't do
that in an argument you want to do it
more I don't know what did you ever go
out of that [ __ ] but I bet you wrong age
like 50 when you're just like I'm too
[ __ ] old fifties not that old I don't
know my parents still fight like that
when do you stop doing dumb [ __ ]
do you ever always do I hope I never do
a dumb [ __ ] yeah I love it I don't know
man I feel like I value my knees too
much and like what a dumb [ __ ] dude I
put tore my ACL twice now doing what
like football but I that is tight a
quarterback and drop a guitar now flag
football new cleats it hurt sometimes
I'm driving on the freeway I close my
eyes real quick when I try to see how
long full of lies I've done that before
dumb [ __ ] yeah absolutely [ __ ] I did
that like three weeks ago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]